if we live in the metaverse and put
goggles on our head and believe that we
look like Brad Pitt all day long and
that we are very attractive next to
celebrities you know we may feel good
about ourselves but it will not be the
reality that we all share and the same
if you take recreational drugs you may
feel high and very good and but it's not
the reality now
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
or if there was a news media back and
two and a half billion years ago they
would say some good news and some bad
news about life in the solar system
because what happened was that Mars lost
its atmosphere around that time
and it used to have liquid water on the
surface it's pretty obvious based on all
the data we have from the perseverance
Rover more most recently so there was
clearly there were clearly lakes and
eventually for some mysterious reason
Mars lost its atmosphere I mean it it
has a much lower gravity than the earth
but there was some event that caused it
to lose its atmosphere and as a result
all liquid water on its surface all life
forms so we might find evidence that
life existed on early Mars because it
was not very different from Earth early
Earth now around the same time two and a
half billion years that's a complete it
could be a complete coincidence or maybe
not but the oxygen level in the
atmosphere of Earth Rose abruptly we
don't know why I mean we didn't know
what produced the oxygen cyanobacteria
but we don't know why there was this
sudden rise in the oxygen level and that
of course enabled all the chemistry that
allowed complex life forms like
ourselves to exist there wasn't much
oxygen in the first half of the life of
the earth and both both events occurred
at the same time there was bad news on
Mars good news on Earth for intelligent
life or complex life and maybe they were
related I don't know but when we look at
other planets one thing to keep in mind
is you know that we have a 50 chance to
conclude the
to conclude that life exists if there is
oxygen because there was microbial life
on Earth for half of its life without
much oxygen in the atmosphere and the
second is that within a billion years
from now the sun will boil off all the
oceans on Earth okay so even Earth will
lose its atmosphere and the water on its
surface and that's one billion years
from now so that's like 20 percent left
you know we don't have much time left
one thing to keep in mind most stars
like the sun formed five billion years
before the Sun so they already went
through that now we didn't hear the
cries for help from those civilizations
that were on this habitable planets like
the Earth and said wow we are losing our
you know atmosphere we're losing our
oceans we're losing everything and we
and they cried for help there must have
been sort of a a an immediate Exodus
they must have sent lots of spacecraft
in fact most of the interstellar objects
most of the interstellers crafts may
have been launched at this last phase
when the civilizations that were highly
evolved technologically realize we're
about to die my point is that's
something to keep in mind when we look
for seti Sigma radio signals you know
they cannot come from a star that
evolved into the red giant phase you
know like most of the sunlight Stars
went through that and therefore just
forget about it what makes us think that
if you come up with proof or Avi comes
up with some discovery that anything
will be different 20 years from now
to me science and it's a learning
experience about reality okay so it's
because we it allows us to adapt to it
if we have the wrong ideas if we live in
the metaverse and put goggles on our
head and believe that we look like Brad
Pitt all day long and that we are very
attractive next to celebrities you know
we may feel good about ourselves but it
will not be the reality that we all
share and the same if you take
recreational drugs you may feel high and
very good and but it's not the reality
that now the scientific inquiry allows
us to figure out what reality is and
sometimes it contradicts our you know
prior beliefs like quantum mechanics you
know it was in conflict with the
traditional thinking and Einstein had a
problem with that but he was wrong okay
so the point of the matter is that by
understanding why you are wrong you can
then realize how to cope with the new
sense of reality so for example if you
know that the Earth moves around the sun
when you design a space mission you take
that into account if you believe very
this decisively that the sun moves
around the earth you will never get to
your destination by launching a rocket
okay because you have the wrong idea so
reality is whatever it is and we better
adapt to it and the only way to do that
is by you know collecting data not human
beings are not scientific sensors
they're not scientific tools we learn
that over history that's why we are
using instruments and that's what
Science is based on so collecting
quantitative data understanding your
instruments and then learning something
new about reality will benefit us no
matter what we find
foreign
[Music]